je respire géopoliticien chercheur à la
fais moi bonsoir et merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur lg france
quel est le sens de ce type d'événement
il s'agit évidemment de commémorer la
victoire sur l'allemagne nazie mais
est-ce que ça va aussi un peu au delà de
ça je pense qu'il y à différentes
orientations la première est une
orientation à de célébration nationale
d'ailleurs à à petit de clin d'oeil la
publication de l'article de vladimir
poutine aux autres atlantique s'est fait
dans le journal qui s'appelle national
interest n'est ce pas donc intérêt
national donc il est bien évident que il
est tout à fait normal que la russie
célèbre une victoire sur l'allemagne
nazie elle en a payé à un prix fort
élevée et d'autre
donc il y a dans une semaine aussi à un
référendum dans quoi il s'agit mais
aussi peut-être de mobiliser l'attention
et le sentiment nationaliste et
deuxièmement donc il ya une contribution
à est évidente de la russie de l'union
soviétique de l'époque à l'écrasement du
nazisme
vous évoquiez à l'instant cet article
rédigé il ya quelques jours par la
dîmière poutine dans lequel il pointait
du doigt la remise en cause de l'urss
dont la seconde guerre mondiale
ils considèrent comme du révisionnisme
anti russe ils considèrent ils mettent
en avant ce révisionnisme anti russe de
la part des européens
là il n'est pas revenu sur ses propos ce
matin mais c'était quand même dans tous
les esprits oui et je crois qu'il est
toujours très très très délicat de
remobiliser et de rappeler l'histoire
parce que la grande dame histoire est
une dame à deux visages
l'histoire est un janus avec un visage
blanc et à visage noir j'évoquais
l'union soviétique et bien avant la
victoire de 1945 il y a quand même eu
visage noir
le pacte germano-soviétique de 1939 qui
a vu l'écrasement de la pologne divisé
dont contre l'armée soviétique et
l'armée nazie à voyez vous donc il faut
toujours être très très prudent quand on
rompt mobile
histoire et bien il faut accepter les
deux visages de l'histoire vladimir
poutine a appelé ce matin la communauté
internationale à l'unité pour faire face
aux défis d'aujourd'hui lancé insisté
sur l'importance de l'amitié la
confiance entre les peuples et du
dialogue et de la coopération sur les
questions actuelles qui sont à l'agenda
international c'était un message
important qu'il a tenté de faire passer
ce matin il ya de grandes négociations
effectivement en cours on célèbre la fin
d'une guerre il y à de grands
négociations sur la limitation des
armements stratégiques en cours donc les
états unis souhaitent que la chine ils
soient associés a donc vous voyez vous
il y ait vraiment il est vraiment très
important que ces négociations puissent
avoir lieu et aboutissent à des
réductions à l'intérieur nombre de têtes
nucléaires détenues par les principales
puissances dans les tribunes officielles
ce matin il avait une dizaine de chefs
d'état étrangers notamment d'asie
centrale beaucoup ont dû décliner
l'invitation c'est la photo que vides je
pense qu'il y a comme d'habitude un
mélange des deux je pense qu'il ya une
certaine prudence par rapport à un
certain nombre de décisions et
d'activités russa l'un à l'extérieur des
frontières russes
donc voilà je pense qu'il ya une
certaine prudence diplomatique
et puis effectivement n'oublions pas que
journellement depuis des mois
actuellement il y as entre sept et huit
mille nouveaux cas de comics 19 en
russie donc il y a effectivement un
problème sanitaire
il fallait prendre des décisions les
décisions étaient effectivement de
maintenir la célébration du 24 juin
cette présence française ce matin à
celle là vu de l'ambassadeur français de
russie on se souvient de cette petite
polémique en amont un de l'organisation
de ces commémorations
concernant emmanuel macron invité par
invité est-ce que
c'est un message est ce qu'est ce que ça
dit des relations aujourd'hui entre la
russie et la france
oh rien de spécial parce que si le
président macron avait été absent et que
madame merkel étaient présentes là il y
avait un message annoncé l'ensemble les
la grande bretagne non plus n'est pas
représentée à haut à son plus haut
niveau
donc c'est l'ensemble des pays
occidentaux qui n'ont pas fait ce
déplacement
donc il n'ya pas de message de la france
où un message vers la france spéciale
merci beaucoup gérer un vestiaire
d'avoir pris le temps de répondre à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
géopoliticien chercheur à la ferme